I'm getting excited I'm getting actually
Oscars coming up yeah so you'd say about
the Oscars are a little exciting
I think there's some really good movies
these years there's great movies this
year yeah it's amazing the Oscars of
course are Sunday and just to prepare
you it could be a very long night the
results are being tabulated by the Iowa
Democrats everybody gets to go up and
give an acceptance speech and then three
days later you find out okay yeah 19:17
all right okay
19:17 did you see that movie that's a
good movie yeah yeah the the movie 1917
is apparently the favorite to win Best
Picture at this year's Oscars yeah yeah
cool story yeah 1917 is about Bernie
Sanders freshman year of high school
well he's the same he's still the same
yeah Oscar's were this Sunday
one of the movies up for a few awards is
the two popes yeah and that stars
Anthony Hopkins as Pope Benedict and
Jonathan Pryce as Cardinal bergoglio and
and he would later become of course
Pope Francis now I thought it was quite
a compelling character study and I
really liked the movie but there was one
moment I found very distracting and it
was a cameo in the movie that just felt
kind of forced and took me out of the
picture it happened in a scene where the
two men are charting a course for who
will be the next pope see if you feel
the same way now I can see a necessity
for a Peugeot Leo I can't do this
without knowing that there is at least a
possibility that you might be chosen no
it could never be me all right we're at
an impasse my sons
work it out someone's got to be Pope
[Music]
wouldn't Jesus have a better bicycle and
you can't ride a bike through the
Vatican yeah I met out the hard way yeah
[Laughter]
that's your problem with the clip yeah
that way that's what you meant
yeah a lot of stairs yeah yeah yeah